c'est inacceptable a fustigé le maire de
londres exclus des discussions pour
planifier l'éventuelle reconfirme ans de
la capitale en cas de reprise de
l'épidémie
sadik khan a adressé une lettre
tranchante à boris johnson c'est
totalement inacceptable pour londres et
les londoniens qu'un plan d'urgence de
si grande envergure ait pu être discutée
tester sans inclure ni en informer les
autorités de londres exclure les
dirigeants locaux de cette façon ne nous
aidera pas à maîtriser le virus cela
doit cesser immédiatement selon le plan
décidé mercredi le comité de crise de
haut niveau du gouvernement envisage de
placer londres et sa banlieue sous
cloche si une seconde vague venait à se
déclarer le maire travailliste de
londres critiques depuis le début de la
crise la lenteur de boris johnson à
prendre des décisions
le premier ministre qui a déclaré lui il
y a quatre jours qu'ils réagiraient
rapidement en cas de rebond de
l'épidémie adwea series rises en voyant
les augmentations du nombre de cas dans
le monde
on ne peut pas se voiler la face et se
dire que nous serons épargnés
nous devons pouvoir réagir dès les
premiers signes d' alerte aujourd'hui le
rapport hebdomadaire du bureau national
des statistiques
affirme que la prévalence du virus en
angleterre a des chances d'augmenter
pour la première fois depuis mai ces
mesures de prévention sont mises en
place
alors que depuis la fin du mois de juin
plusieurs pays européens subissent une
recrudescence des contaminations forçant
les autorités à reconfirmer localement
certaines villes